un bonheur avec cette chienne
Frank je vous verrai dans quelques mois vous tous
hé ta mère me rend visite hé
où est son frère tu as des couilles
qui se présentent ici mec je suis désolé mec je
vais arranger les choses
je te veux contre  le numéro un mondial ne
peut pas rencontrer mon garçon donne-nous un ascenseur
appelle-moi tu conduis
[ __ ] retourne le monde contre moi mon
Robby ne peut pas marcher ils vont te tuer [ __ ]
frère ils vont même tuer Emily tu
penses que je ne sais pas  à propos de ta petite
copine elle ne sait rien je
jure devant Dieu il a essayé de nous piéger je
quitte la
ville c'est notre
banque c'est notre guerre ok maman on est là pour
dévaliser la banque pas toi les
banques sont une menace essentielle  à notre
démocratie alors considérez cette justice
ne jouez pas un film avec moi
mon domaine va mal
vous